here to present to you one of the main
dishes of the state of the union packets
are proposals on a new Africa Europe
alliance without further ado I will
start with the High Representative as
president thank you you might remember
that when we started our Monday it's
four years ago we said that it was not
enough it was not good anymore to work
just for Africa but that we wanted to
shift the paradigm and start working
with happy in this last four years with
then building step by step a different
kind of partnership with Africa
partnership of equals with the continent
that is the closest one to Europe only
14 kilometres away from our coasts
continents whose development security
guarantees also Europe's development and
security so we have turned the page
somehow shifting from a donor recipient
kind of relationship the traditional one
based on development aid and
humanitarian aid to a partnership based
first and foremost on our political
partnership we work with Africa very
closely on most of the global issues
starting from the multilateral
frameworks in the United Nations we work
with Africa very closely on peace and
security especially in the Sahel in the
Horn of Africa and all the different
many crises that are there but we have
started since a couple of years together
with West Kassadin Catina and
Commissioner mamita to work on the
economic partnership between the
European Union and Africa so now we are
taking a new step in this direction
launching an Africa Europe Alliance for
sustainable investments and jobs and
this will be a major priority for our
work in the year ahead
this is a commitment we have taken and
we've discussed with our African
partners last year when we had the EU
African Union summit in Abidjan where we
discuss
together with our African partners the
fact that we have a joint interest in
investing in all the rest development
aid stays but all the rest is also
important and so trade economic
relations investments including privates
once so over the last year's we have
already strengthened our cooperation
with Africa enormously and we have you
might remember that a couple of years
ago launched a European external
investment plan to bring more private
investments in Africa now next step
today is to deepen our trade and
investment relationship we are already
and by far Africa's first partner in
trade and investment and development I
can give you a couple of numbers we are
Africa Strait is 436 percent with the
European Union the European Investment
is also almost three hundred billion
euros a year and I hear a lot about
China
presence in Africa let me give you one
number if you trade with Africa is 36
percent China trade with Africa is 16
percent if yo foreign direct investment
in Africa is 40 percent
China is five percent so I think that it
would be good for us to realize how
strong our partnership already is and
now we are proposing to increase it to a
new level
ear ki and Navin will share more details
about the proposal itself but I would
like to underline one specific point
that is particularly close to my heart
and also to my work in these years if
the investment on the younger generation
of the continent that sometimes is seen
as a ticking bomb
while it is actually the greatest
opportunity for growth of the continent
every time we've traveled to Africa I've
done it many times in this last year's
we meet young entrepreneurs that are
creating for instance online services
with young women that are starting
businesses mixing tradition
and innovation and providing services to
their communities and these are only two
aspects of the creativity of a young
generation in Africa that is ready and
willing to work for the economic
development of their own continent so
they often lack education and training
and they often lack access to financial
opportunities and this is why we have
proposed with this package instruments
to support the younger generation of
Africa first of all we will propose we
propose to support Africa's own kind of
Erasmus scheme with more funding to
education that would allow the African
youth to invest in their own training
and education we will increase our
support for scholarships and exchange
programs with the goal of over 100,000
students benefiting from Erasmus plus in
the next 10 years and with the goal also
give in vocational training to 700 700
550 thousand young Africans by 2020
there is a huge potential in Africa I
know that we always refer to the
continent in relation to either
migration or conflicts and crises the
idea of this package is to focus on the
opportunities and on the common interest
we have to work together in partnership
on economic development so I will be
traveling again to Africa next month in
particular in the on of Africa and also
to meet again with our friends in the
African Union to follow up on this
proposals and there will be also
opportunities for me personally for
others from us to discuss this ideas and
these proposals at the next General
Assembly in New York in ten days from
now thank you
now the vice-president on the economic
perspective thank you very much like
Federico I said in the beginning of this
mandate we wanted to try to say the
modern size we cooperated Africa
and since that we have wanted to look at
various fields of cooperation including
Economic Cooperation how to modernize
them the ways we use existing resources
or additional resources more effectively
investing in this strategic economic
sectors in Africa in skills improving
the business and investment climate and
boosting intra Africa and new Africa
trade can deeply contribute to creating
growth and jobs in and stability in
Africa he is determined to play a key
role to achieve this in the future and
for that we want to help boost
investment in Africa drawing the lessons
from the successful investment plan for
Europe model in the you to do so we can
use public money to attract private
investment much more efficiently and
achieve better result with a strong
ownership in our partner countries so
what we are next proposing is based on
lessons learned from invest you program
so we have successfully as you know
managed to wake up sleep in private
liquidity in the bank accounts and and
wanted to include this private liquidity
to build in Europe so by providing
current ease we have managed to the
crowd in private resources for
productive investment we already
launched the external image plan in 2016
which by using the euro budget current
ease of just 4.1 billion years is
expected to generate up to forty four
billion years of investment by 2020 this
is on track in July we gave the green
light to the package of currently
programs set to check around nine
billion years in investment Navin can
keep more information on on this issue
looking at the future we want to
continue using this model for long
you budget for 2021 2027 and create an
external investment platform that will
multiply available funds by bringing
together the EU budget and funds from
the EIP group you bank the EP Rd Member
States Development Bank's and private
sector this will allow us to leverage
the you budget so as to invest more in
Africa our neighbourhood and beyond we
indeed believe there is a scope for
closer collaboration between these
actors to benefit from the respective
experience and expertise while
maintaining diversity in the market this
can be done for example through regional
anthem attic specialization of partners
or joint initiatives one successful
example of coordination already in place
is the best Americans investment
framework in which the EIB and the EBRD
our joint partners alongside the
Commission the Council of Europe
Development Bank and several bilateral
donors this initiative provides
financing and technical assistance to
strategic investments in energy
environmental social transport and
digital infrastructure such a model
could be replicated commissioned
together with member states will retain
the political steer on external actions
activities we will finance to ensure
consistency with external policy
objectives but let me be very clear we
don't aim and do not have the capacity
to become a bank
we will only keep the policy tier and
manage the currently provided from the
EU budget to development partners so
development part implemented partners
are the ones who do due diligence and do
the banking decisions our role is to
look at that you taxpayers money is used
for the policy perspective follow the
policy objectives with the Commission
together with member states have design
yep yes thank you thank you very much
indeed
so let's me go into some more details on
the new europe/africa Alliance for
sustainable investments and job that
President Juncker announced on Wednesday
Africa and the European Union are
already close partners with a strong
political framework what is missing
though is a coherent economic strategy
coherent joint economic strategy this is
precisely the ambition of a new alliance
to develop more the economic angle of
the partnership as in order to give it a
real chance to deliver beyond words and
it is so important for our overall
partnership with Africa to strengthen
the job investments alliance because
Africa is a giant sleeping at our feet
with enormous potential to to affect our
future economic political social future
positively or negatively and all the way
around is equally valid
so therefore Africa is our twin
continent and we have to concentrate I
would say on a four axis of the of this
new economic alliance that we are
proposing so the first acts should be
the boosting strategic investments for
job creation and strengthen the role of
the private sector it is so important to
upgrade to upscale our grant public
money potential that that we invest in
Africa already already now over 20 23
billion euros of official development
assistance of grants of public money go
from member states and European Union to
Africa every year but we can do much
more out of our grant capacity in order
to do to bring part of it into blending
into guarantee supported schemes in
order to leverage our overall develop
and impact in Africa special investment
impact and and and the growth grace and
impact to de to the much much higher
level
so therefore the we shall now continue
to develop further the growth and jobs
context the compacts that are currently
under discussion with most of our
African partners because we do not want
to come to Africa with our investment
proposals investments investments
project it must be and it will be a
joint economic investment exercise that
is based on the on the development
priorities of our African partners so
the the ownership of this is important
to be to be put together with African
partners on the basis of the oddity
launched and established Task Forces on
several important sectors of future
investments like in agriculture we did
it for digitalization as well we are now
in a process of extending these task
forces to bring together African and
European public private financial
operators in other sectors like like
energy renewable energy and transport
for instance the second point second
line of action is to invest in people in
education in skills we will work on
addressing the mismatch between skills
and jobs by supporting the African Union
skills initiative for example what we
want to achieve by such a Alliance by
this alliance is to increase
substantially the employment and
employability in Africa this is this is
important important part of our second
second line of action thirdly the
business environment and the investment
climate are to be improved they have to
be improved and we will work on
strengthen dialogue and cooperation with
our Africa
partners idea our idea is to step up
joint efforts to develop more domestic
resource mobilization and to fight
illicit financial flows as well together
together and primarily with our African
partners and force we have to tap the
full potential of economic integration
and trade economic integration in Africa
and trade relations between Africa and
the European Union we will support the
negotiations on the implementation of
the Africa continental free trade area
we will also support better exploiting
our existing regimes to facilitate trade
with Europe and existing and forthcoming
economic partnership agreement they
should be based also a basis for our
next step for our continent to continent
free trade agreement between the EU and
Africa in the in the longer term as our
vision is our goal so so to deliver
these ambitions important financial
resources already available and the
current financial framework but we
already proposed for the next mff
increased grant capacity increased by
almost 95% and increase guarantee
schemes that that that would enable
investment and jobs jobs Alliance to
really to to flow this new alliance is a
powerful signal that we should think
about Africa in a positive terms that is
very important do European Union and its
member states already doing lots in the
official development assistance to
Africa but but we really have to
transform it as much as possible into
into our overall investment alliance to
add investments to to our grass
projects what we as a commission as this
commission what we can have as a hard
fact is our ongoing external investment
plan we are now after first leg first
tranche of this of this exercise we are
very could almost guarantee that there
will be 24 billion over new investments
under only as in Africa and the
neighborhood only and under the half of
the guarantee schemes used we are now on
a best way to to leverage 44 billion in
Africa until 2020 of a new additional
investments that would otherwise not
happen with our without our blending and
guarantee support this is an excellent
basis if continued if stepped up within
the new mff period that we could really
think of of almost ten times more
investments in job creation investments
in Africa until 2027 this is what I
assess not commissioned yet because this
commission can assess and and and and
set our our targets until 2020 but for
the new mff based on a good work that we
have in investments in Africa right now
we can really substantially
substantially increase our our strategic
investments for job creation and
engagement of private sector in Africa
so my last point is that that we are
often trapped into cliche and negative
images of Africa notably because of the
migration issue launching an initiative
like this one whose objective is to
boost investment will help overcoming
those outdated images and
and reminding us of the dynamism and of
the potential of our African partners
and this is what we would like not only
to see but to contribute to in our
future future actions thank you thank to
all three of you before we switch to
your questions simply a message for the
president that the president will travel
to the United Nations General Assembly
this year and of course the Africa
package would be very much at the heart
of his discussions there with the
secretary-general bhootish
and president of the African Union
President Kagame let's start with Europe
can you please specify from which angle
and to whom so that we can all come to
you Olivia
we start with Urich yakushiji from the
newspaper de soie it's so it's a general
angle and question may be addressed to
all of you but more particularly maybe
because it's general to high represent
and mogherini many things change in the
world and changed in the last years but
one thing that does not change is the
regularity of the grand announcements of
plans on on on Africa and what does not
change is the discrepancy or the gap
between the scale of the ambitions
announced and the reality it's also
regularly for 20 years on the agenda and
in the statements of the Jews
six or seven and eight and then again
seven and 20s and I don't remember how
many geez
Africa is said being very important but
the result is still the same gap so what
can make us believe I hear that there is
one at least one there are more not one
novelty which is a kind of younger plan
let's say methodology here for Africa
okay but more globally you are speaking
of a change of paradigm what make us
believe that there will be the way so
you you will work out not only the EU
but the Member States you will make
succeed in a change of paradigm and
specifically maybe there are many
obstacles in these grand alliances or
planned alliance with Africa on one side
in Africa
it's the rule of law in corruption which
in turn is often contributes to the
feeling of arrogance that they feel from
the the European side and also on the US
side you are speaking about you are
talking about trade but for instance
just as an example the Common
Agricultural Policy is very often
considered as not benefiting or even
being detrimental to to trade with with
Africa so considering all that what can
make us believe that this is not one one
new next grant announcement with the
same result thank you the easy question
would be wait and see but that would be
too easy I I would say as the Africans
or just look at what our partners in
Africa starting from the president of
the African Union Commission mostefai
stated last time he was here in Brussels
or our friends from the g5 Sahel last
time they were here in June and they
here regularly asked them what has
changed in this months in this couple of
years and what they see is changing in
the European Union attitude compared to
a few years ago and they reply they
replied already in this last couple of
months and they will reply again I
believe that what has changed is that
the approach now is based on partnership
I mentioned the fact that this plan this
package is based on discussions we had
at the last summit in Abidjan between
the African Union and the European Union
and the turning point has been that
there we discussed together with the
African Union and the member states of
the African Union their priorities and
see where their priorities matched our
priorities and we found out that
economic investments jobs creation trade
was a common priority for both of us for
different reasons
but ask our business community in Europe
across the continent if they don't know
already that Africa is a big market and
has a lot of potential for investments
for its structures for energy for
digital and unions so there is here a
new not only a new narrative which is
also important but there is a new
approach that we discuss priorities
together and we put forward proposals
that respond not only to our interest
but also to their interest and there's
also the money there is a different
approach that is based on the experience
of the younger plan there is an approach
that mixes our budgets that is already
enormous for Africa I asked to get a an
approximate figure of how many how much
money the European Union puts on Africa
on the different sectors every year and
it's more or less 20 billion euros a
year so our money in Africa is a lot now
the effort is to bring also the private
investments in Africa with an eye to the
environment they're going to invest in -
you mentioned that this is very
important anti-corruption rule of law
human rights not afraid of saying that
on the contrary quite outspoken on that
the role of youth and women in their
societies transparency participation and
the less could continue this is also
part of an investment in an environment
that would attract investments and trade
and that would make the economic
development of Africa much more
sustainable and effective so there is a
lot that has changed obviously this
effort will need to be sustained by our
member states as well and here I make an
appeal to our member states to be
coherent because when they say that
Africa is a priority and must be the
priority and they ask for the Commission
to put EU budget into that kind of relay
then they have to match it with national
budgets and this is let's say still to
be properly done at least by many and we
are discussing now with the development
ministers on the other side of the
square
exactly priority in the priority of our
relationship with Africa I think that
the real change would be when he will
discuss with the ministers that work
with him investments in Africa and not
only the development ministers or the
foreign ministers but we'll get there
I'm sure because this is exactly the
kind of approach we are proposing and I
think there is an understanding on the
fact that we have to move forward with
with a much broader and consistent view
very short opinion what Erika said one
of the novelties and our policies is
that the focus is much more now in
private investment in Africa and also
linked to this we are ready to provide
significant amount of current ease
together with friends but but the amount
of current ease are increasing
significantly because this is the way we
can we can leverage our resources and
this is also suitable for private
investment like very like I said before
some 40% of firend our investments in
Africa grants from Europe so there are
already lots of companies involved in in
various businesses in Africa but we
won't increase this increment I think
everybody here agrees that African
countries are full of potential which is
untapped so we want to modernize the way
we finance projects and that's why
current is plays a role I just try to
simplify if there is a I mean our
priority is to improve environmentally
friendly sustainable energy production
in various African countries if there's
a Belgian company who is interested in
investing to one of those countries for
renewable energy but they cannot get
financing because it's seen too risky
taken contact directly belgian
development bank or a IB or EPR D and
asked if they could negotiate a
financial package and and we are helping
those intermediaries by quarantine teh
operation so this the way we we we are
we are working okay then I had Olivia
yes II kissed you on Alma a lot her
present on Cebu permitted we keep the
other colleague choice even though right
no
Sogeti for mogherini see hum exact unit
Africa with marshmallows inside bomba
Angus in event Vicki kate is this
another ghost in killing head in for
Africa women are the a burden from Phil
Demmel Grafton so much be from Steven
Smith see photography don't think
Henin's is he here then Emmanuelle Marco
hats and actually spook stanley pacion
city to strange maneuver Africa Sri
exactly the demography stirs reason
problem for Africa on the magnification
startin Tony kanakam the Perkins
exploring glyph to be common on them
audacity standing lift the competence in
either plane even a finance mechanic
feel better and we conceal pharaohs of
is easy here present Ian fell
equivalents laws Valley of the canonical
nominal form a union jobs schaffen
current video and mention dot GMC
vehicles does the dusty mocha official
problem Africa's the field so stark this
finished active accident of every Kong
and stuffed that English gentleman in
English gentleman Butte when currency
actor else are versatile fun hardened
when a president tons and years this is
the H on mangu fully digit Argos act
this is very girlf Amiata Hakata
Tanzania striking uh come on Norma
mentioned soanian to set up an improv
meet the you know somebody's aunt in
fewer demography chiffon exact thang
let me say as a woman before then as
High Representative that sure having
five seven nine twelve children for a
woman in her lifetime is definitely not
something that I would wish my friends
with my colleagues or my it's beautiful
to have children most beautiful thing in
life but obviously there is a problem
there is a demographic problem in Africa
and let me say it's first and foremost a
demographic problem for the women of
Africa and sometimes this perspective is
missing we only see the problem of the
population growing we don't see this
from the perspective of those that are
giving birth and maybe we should
introduce a human element and this
having said that so yes there is a
challenge there that needs to be tackled
I know that many African leaders
including many women there are African
leaders are trying to address this in a
context that has a culture and a
tradition that is not used to manage
with this having said that I would
always refused to consider the young
generation of Africa problem in itself
because I have met them I know them we
have been working with them across the
continents over this last four years and
I can tell you when you point out at the
lack of transparency you point out at
the corruption when you point out the
problem of rule of law democracy of
participation the answer is in the
younger generation of Africa so no the
youth of Africa is not problem the youth
of Africa is the biggest resource Africa
has I guess and I know together with the
women of Africa and especially the young
women of Africa because then we always
separate the two categories forgetting
that there are also young women that are
taking a growing space in societies
there and this is something we are
supporting doesn't mean that we deny
that there is
challenging the continents but we cannot
imagine that a generation or a couple of
generations for the continent are are a
burden no they are the best energy of
the continent they are incredibly
willing to invest in their own continent
in their own way but they're missing
they're lacking the means for doing that
and this is why I focused in my
introduction especially on our
investment on education for the African
youth and on the support that we're
trying to give in particular to youth in
across all the different sectors of
support and investment in this package
okay then I had you on the left
Phillips eliminates my question is to
vice-president Katainen
you launch the external investment plan
already some time ago and its component
the sustainable development fund I think
it's called how big is the interest to
date how many companies from Europe want
to use its financial instruments and
invest in Africa and secondly do you
foresee a change in agricultural policy
in the European Union in particular
subsidies so to make it better cope with
the situation in Africa where it is said
too often to produce a too big market
power of Europe
so I guess Never Knows actually in
detail how much the investment plan
external investment plan has already
been used but what I said and even also
mentioned in our introductory remark we
launched in July we released few sets of
current ease for new investments which
will trigger some nine billion of
investments in in our under our
investment program but motrin is
speaking if listening what private
sector is saying is that there are
countries or regions in Africa where the
growth prospects are very fascinating
and but still do the franchise situation
or the market situation risks are high
and that's why the cost of financing is
also high say it's not only Chinese
companies but also the European
companies which are which are looking
more more African opportunities than
they did some while ago and that has
encouraged us to look at investment
external investment plan from private
investors perspective we hear the
similar news from the member states say
that they want to to help take companies
to invest in Africa if if there's a
demand so using yo current East or how
much you current is are used is based on
demand so this is different than
traditional still valid and important
development aid which is in the form of
grants so current these are purely
demand driven they aren't used if nobody
wants to use them but they are used if
if there is a demand for this and and
our understanding is that there is a
demand and it's very possibly that
the Krantz plays a crucial role because
every all the investments are not
economically viable but they are still
important but at the same time we have
to release another part of the economy
which is private economy to do their job
like they do it elsewhere but even if
you yes the level of investment interest
of European companies in Africa is
encouraging I can say that on the basis
of our first first part of engaging the
guarantee schemes and blending
facilities under the already launched
external investment plan when it comes
to Toto to guarantees that that that
should cover the investment in a riskier
environment like in Africa the the level
of the of the proposed investments
asking seeking for the guarantee was
almost double than the than the overall
gallon guarantee scheme we had 1.5 1.6
billion euros this is the guarantee
level that we have under the external
investment plan until 2020 and the
requests coming or proposals for
investments were asking for over 3
billion euros of guarantees so we had I
would say a pleasant maybe not easy but
but at least encouraging work Toto to
look and to select the real investment
projects with the most of the additional
development impact in in Africa some of
these project requests were not able to
do or not good enough to fail to cope
with with a risk assessment part of our
of our selection process but the other
work almost equally equally valid for
for increasing the impact of our
investment in Africa so therefore based
on the
experience that already leveraged or we
leverage up to nine billion euros by
using half eight hundred million of
guarantee schemes and adding the the
blending capacity that that that makes
DDD investment financing investment
loans down to the most concessional
level that goes almost right now to over
15 million of euros of investment so
altogether twenty four billion euros of
investments this give us really
confidence in the indie indie assessment
that by 2020 forty four billion euros
over new investments in Africa will be
will be rich will be possible to reach
having in mind the level of a order the
existing investment interest okay I have
carrot on a boost in and then we switch
and you and then we switch to to me day
please let's try to cover in your angles
yes character the radical in Italian if
I may mr. president love each opposition
to make a teeny Documenta after script
okay know peteyboo the lungo periodic
Western Lanza btvehicle OD au revoir au
n-- area the Liberals cambio tribunal
European a Africa volley Voki Delhi say
realistic odor punto de vista political
a very quest objective on a momentum qui
in a row pencil pies I can't rhyme
because I'm a Leo
she's oh no for sell govern okay dick on
you know Perez MPO aliquot liberated at
see the lowly Tunisian okay aerostat
intro do tau Terrell economy a tuna
Zenon el momento de la tentativa de la
forza la democracia della
tunisia and they would have a second
question to vice president cation if I
may on another topic yesterday the
president of the Stock Exchange
authority in Italy
step down following huge political
pressure that we you don't mind we can
take this and made a secret of a
surrealistic Oh
political meant Eden Kadem Punto de
vista economic oh no period olecranon
area deliver Escambia Africa a una
Naropa Institute Oh / que la Africa's
Tolliver and Oh Alec Rosanna do know su
area deliver us cameo in hola Stamos
Austin and Abby amo the she sewed the
sustainer Cousteau laborda Luna photonic
razuna libros cambio africana cone chin
quant Emilio need the arrow in it CRE
requested we show to the villa venti
prima di tutto / k sustained air lucano
mia in tariff free Carnegie's Kimiko
mercalli traffic on e you modo
fundamentally para encourage our
sustainer euros aloof economic Oh a POI
/ que la prossima Tata graphic Amita
culturally storica keelaurow back on
laughs rica pork on center chain in
prospect ela Kiera meant ad a very very
Bustos scenario
non so tanto low vision and Cydia
graphical Emma numerical schita to
Bremen Giada so he Benny comer chatty in
Africa Kunal Africa so no it's Rita
separate from me until me on European
see I mean preemie partners how much
idle Africa's me preemie invest eat or
in Africa confer on taper canto
then investiment East Ranieri shebang
gonna repay Putin italiana della valle
de pinna Farlow space so pension OPC a
latina Allah presents economic a p14
Africa lishchyna invest in Africa chinko
/ Trento repair Barranca percent of the
investment ago some presence in Africa
quindi twist Abbas dear Alex uneconomic
afford a 40 C McCain Austrian predatory
or OPEC oh no score emotive Anna Hazare
alabaster realistic ax / la barrera in
prospective averse una zona de Pras
cambio term Europa Africa Testament a
historic a day Richard era
Makeda riba una política courante non so
tanto de parte del Satoshi on a rope a
mask a departed olicity memory
fortune is a medium Oprah posto do men
tarde el treinta % o in barranco de luna
no repay across no period often on CRE o
dedicado al sunnah stair Madeleine Jana
abbiamo propos'd o D provide air para
trás immobile ancho repay o Cuarenta
mille r DD l ro da de de car al no
stroller O'Connell Africa yes Beth
Tokido study memory k dick oh no ok
lavoro fun laugh like a Puritan are uses
tengo esta la posta I was in Africa
Africa or something else
Union president Juncker he spoke a lot
about Africa but he also mentioned the
need that the EU speaks with one voice
once and for all
also onwards Western Balkans so I would
ask Madame o Guarini because she
experienced this lack of unity of you
when it comes to the Western Balkans
beat for the future enlargement or cross
or status whatever turn out to be
trouble as troubled region s Africa if
something is not done soon so do you
still believe that European Union will
support the solution in relations
between Kosovo and Serbia if the
solution is exchange of territory which
means the changing of borders of
existing countries most of whom are also
candidate countries and potential
candidates for EU I think we stick to
Africa here but I have answered your
question many times in the last 10 days
so you can go and check my statements
but yes I still believe that solution is
possible
ok concludes our press conference thanks
to all three of you we switch to me day
in two minutes
you